we got the story from townhall.com
bipartisan CBS focus group stuns host
when panelists agree on almost
everything including woke culture so the
clips actually a bit long what do we
have it's like three and a half minutes
so I'm not I'm not going to play the
full thing for you but it really really
is amazing you've got a republican a
Democrat and an independent and then
they're all just like she asked the
Republican guy and he's like you know I
just don't like this indoctrination of
kids in schools with the weird sexual
stuff that's for adults we shouldn't
have that and then she's like is this
your kids he's like no I'm in Texas but
where I was in Iowa it was bad and she
was okay so you're mad about what's on
the news then it goes to the black woman
in the top left and she's like I agree
with all of that I think it's horrible
I've got a bunch of kids then it goes to
them in the bottom right and she's like
yeah I completely agree and and you know
even with the vaccine mandates and stuff
like that in the lockdowns so here we
have one of the most shocking I guess
you know uh panel panels so far in the
midterms we're in the middle of the
midterms because we no longer do
election day now it's election month
right and we're seeing that at least
here
everyone completely agrees so I'm
wondering I I I uh retweeted this person
does a I don't know who this person is
on Twitter it's a small account with a
few followers saying come the midterms
Democrats are going to win and the media
is going to ask how could this have
happened and it's because Democrats are
secretly you know hiding and Republicans
are secretly switching to the Democratic
party and there's no evidence for that
claim but I'm like all right you know
I'll I'll retweet that and say let's
let's revisit this one on the ninth and
see what happens I think this is more
evidence along with all the polling
which is insane the 538 forecast now has
basically a coin toss chance that
Republicans win both Chambers and an 81
chance they at least win the house I
feel like looking at this it's not so
much that it's a red wave a red tsunami
it's that Democrats are quitting
Independents are flipping and
Republicans are already 99 I have a good
conspiracy theory for you around oh
conspiracy so the Democrats so
traditionally when especially there's a
Democrat president
um in charge we know that it's swings to
the opposite Party come midterms so they
already knew because you know of the the
way the economy is and gas prices and
whatever I think they're chalking it up
letting us win that's why they're
dumping money into like these right-wing
campaigns and stuff right you see the
Veritas video yeah so but my point is
what they're going to do is they're
going to let us have control of the
house and and the Senate so that we can
you know our base no matter what is like
not strategic and they're going to be
like you're not in there you're not
doing enough so then they're going to
start pushing in because we've got these
further right candidates they're going
to start pushing in more far-right
policies that way when it comes time for
them to get the house the Senate and
um
the White House again come 2024 that
it's going to be way easier because
they're going to go point to all our
terrible policies and that's where the
Republicans have to chill about it you
think Joe Biden is going to sign these
policies in the law you think
Republicans are going to the house in
the Senate's gonna pass a bill and
Biden's gonna be like okay I guess you
know I mean depending on what it is it
doesn't matter not just not not just
that but the Democrats have no a-listers
none name a democratic Minister I can't
name one anybody not anybody that's
worth their salt like who's like in the
Republic in the Republican party you at
least have Trump and DeSantis right and
I'm sure you could probably throw out a
couple other b-listers but well
swallow's pretty social he's out there
you know I'm meeting a lot of uh who's
got the X Factor but here's the thing it
doesn't it I don't think it really
matters because if they our base will
push us to start like proposing radical
policies and even if Biden doesn't do it
they'll say you need to keep him in so
that they don't ruin our country with
all these crazy things that they're
trying to implement
they might say look at the Republican
bills that they tried to get through and
Biden blocked if Biden doesn't get
reelected they're getting these things
through you're also you know thinking
that the Republican Republicans could
get something done I I I I've been very
critical of them personally myself and
you know a lot of the times they come
into office and they kind of just sit on
their hands especially when it comes to
the Congress you will have you will have
your newer people in their proposing
legislation if if you have
um we'll just face Arizona I can't Blake
Masters blade Masters definitely going
to want to go in there and like get to
work he's definitely one of those people
but if he gets pushed enough in these
two years by the the right base and
starts promo like putting in policy that
is too far quote right they have
something to run on Big Time in 2024.
the Republicans right now who do they
got they got I mentioned to sandus and
Trump that's easy but Carrie Lake I feel
like Kerry Lake could be president she's
the her the way she speaks the way she's
she's got a commanding presence very
calm and collected very quick-witted do
you think Carrie Lake would want to be
president though
you think so like when we talk what does
that look on your face I just think so I
just think it is
I'm saying I I definitely think that I
mean she's poised to be she's articulate
she's great with the media and everybody
loves her like if you were to pull
regular oh she's amazing right now they
say I'd love to see her be president you
know my biases my bias is when we get
like politicians who have come on this
show and it's like pulling teeth
and it's just like the campaign has got
a bunch of stipulations or there's like
weird things and I'm like I ignore it
I'm like bro you can show up sit down or
whatever so I respect every politicians
come on the show because we don't have
like a prerequisite list of like talking
points we sit down I pull up news
stories we talk for a little bit we go
live and then the conversation goes
where it goes
try I try to be respectful I try to make
sure we're being you know my former boss
when he was on here who was it Randy
babbert we were talking about oh right
right yeah yeah that was great you were
great but Kerry Lake she shows up an MTG
sits down and says sup yeah and it's
like let's just talk and there's no fear
there's no it's just we'll talk about
whatever ask a question that's how it
should be though I I ask as somebody who
would give advice to comps like comms
advice to
um candidates there's so many times
where they just come in Twitter spaces
and stuff and I'm like stop talking if
they were my my like candidate I'd be
like stop talking I mean you do as a
comms person try to protect them but
it's better when they're just real it's
better I mean the authenticity is really
what matters we were we were watching
the DeSantis Chris debate just before we
started this and uh Charlie Chris pulled
a dirty trick because the campaigns
agreed that there would be no cross
questions between the candidates that
let the moderator handle things and
that's the right way to do it otherwise
you start yelling at each other and then
the audience goes nonsense WWE so Chris
goes Ron are you actually going to be
the governor and and finish a four-year
term why don't you answer right now and
then Ron's like is it my time yet okay
anyway and then the the moderator's like
let me remind the candidates you've
agreed not to ask each other questions
and I thought that uh Chris got him
Charlie Chris got him by asking that and
Ron should have just said yes that's
what you said I said that he should have
said I don't know what the political
landscape is like right now but no
matter what I'll take care of I mean I
think it's more honest I I if it were me
and I was debating and someone was like
do you want you want to be president are
you actually running to be governor and
will you finish four terms
is that a serious question yes I'm
standing here aren't I come outside
waste people's time okay obviously I
want to be the governor obviously I'm
here to finish the job do the job and
finish the term out let's not play
stupid political games okay that's a
better answer than just you I'm just but
I'm just so sick of the fake everything
the thing everything when Deepwater
Horizon is my favorite example deep
water Horizon happens and there's oil
spilling everywhere and then the the pr
guy comes out and says we're sorry that
this happened and blah blah and I'm like
bro everyone knows your statement is
bull crap every single time a polishing
comes out we know everything coming out
of nothing I don't care who they are
just trash coming out that's why you
know when Trump trump came out today and
he was like you know what you got to do
to find the leaker you got to take the
writer the guy who write it wrote it and
you got to lock them up and then once he
finds out he's gonna become someone's
husband then he'll flip and I'm like
that's a horrible psychotic thing to say
wow but Trump just came out and said it
that's so crazy that like I didn't hear
that when was that like recently there
was there's a clip going around going
viral War Trump's yeah he's like I know
it's not that released I I tweeted it
it's on my Twitter should I pull it up
are we even allowed to post videos of
trump talking on Twitter anywhere I mean
he's just saying that you should do you
admire that you know he's just willing
to say
crazy things like that I don't like that
he said it I don't like that he holds
the idea the point I'm bringing up is
here it's citizens for ethics the
honesty is refreshing is what you're
saying exactly that this is why people
vote for them they're like well I think
it's bad but but damn if I'd vote for a
liar because when Trump says this
okay so here's a tweet citizens for
ethics says in this horrifying clip
Donald Trump proposes throwing reporters
in jail where they'll be raped until
they give up their sources his crowd
laughed
I think it's terrible thing terrible
thing to believe to say yeah and I think
reporters if if it were me as a reporter
and someone said give me a source I'd be
like nope and if Trump said to me then
you're gonna get locked up and beat and
be raped or whatever or be someone's
boyfriend or husband I'd be like sucks
for you I guess because you ain't
getting anything from me but the point
is
whenever these politicians come out 99.9
of the time you know they're spewing
word diarrhea into your face like a like
a projectile just just spraying you and
you're just like you waste my time good
sir and then Donald Trump comes out and
says this with the Herschel Walker when
like he should have just the easiest way
around the Herschel Walker stuff with
like the abortion and stuff is say I
yeah I did that I'm a different person
it was a couple years ago I'm sorry I've
heard a lot of people in my life and
I've been doing everything I can to make
amends I mean people would have
respected that a thousand times more
than tweeting out like oh that's my son
I love him no matter what like
everybody's rolling their eyes like stop
exactly I was so mad at their camp
campaign staff for that because you know
they're going to the Republicans down
there are going to vote for him instead
of Warnock anyway like let's be fair
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there